Soundgarden and Audioslave frontman
Chris Cornell has died he was 52 Petey
can confirm Chris died unexpectedly in
Detroit Wednesday night according to a
spokesperson for the Detroit Police
Department they found him unresponsive
on the floor and he was later pronounced
dead at the scene when the medic unit
arrived the rockstars rep tells ET his
death is sudden and unexpected he adds
on behalf of Chris's family quote they
would like to thank his fans for their
continuous love and loyalty and asked
that their privacy be respected at this
time the music legend had been on tour
with Soundgarden at the time of his
passing the band was set to headline
rock on the range Music Festival on
Friday a tribute was posted to the site
that read he was a true hero to music
the voice of an angel now watching down
on us as we celebrate and honor him all
weekend long
following the heartbreaking news celeb
shared their condolences on social media
Gavin Rossdale tweeted total shock great
man great band great loss Cornell's
cause of death is still under
investigation
[Music]
you
[Music]